right why did you lie to your daughter
so I wouldn't have to come here why
didn't you want to come here because I
don't respect therapy because I'm a
scientist because I invent transform
create and destroy for a living and when
I don't like something about the world I
change it and I don't think going to a
rented office in a strip mall to listen
to some agent of averageness explain
which words mean which feelings has ever
helped anyone do anything I think it's
helped a lot of people get comfortable
and stop panicking which is a state of
mind we value in the animals who eat but
not something I want for myself I'm not
a cow I'm a pickle when I feel like it
so you asked pickle Rick let's break
this down and there's a new round of
that merch giveaway for Zen monkey
studios all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so as the writers explain the
first part of the episode was sort of
Bible goes West getting sucked down the
drain as a pickle then it turned into
the breaking bad episode where he gets
stuck in the RV in the desert they have
to make that potato battery or think
about it battery is it galvanic so no
more than an anode and the cathode
separated by an electrolyte right just
going through the extreme steps that it
would take for him to engineer himself a
way out of this situation and then once
he escapes out of the toilet it turns
into a big parody of 80s 90s action
films so I think that everybody
recognized that Danny Trejo was playing
Jaguar who's basically like your typical
80s 90s action hero it was probably one
of the best parts of the episode can't
wait to see where they bring Jaguar back
I love the end tag tube which is meant
to be like a funniest side like they're
off on some crazy adventure they're
about ready to die that is why you don't
go to therapy Morty because Jaguar will
come save you and you only would have
met him if he didn't go to therapy if
you really want to be a conspiracy
theorist to Jaguars character design and
look like something out of gravity falls
there's always been a lot of gravity
falls Easter eggs during the first
season there was that portal Easter Egg
during the second season bill cipher
pops up and then during season 3 episode
1 you see the Mabel and dipper Morty in
the background so there's always lots of
gravity falls crossing over with Rick
and Morty you could say that there's a
universe within Rick and Morty that is
gravity falls so it's not so weird the
Jaguar looks like he's from gravity
falls Susan
sarandon of course played doctor Wang
she did an amazing job of deconstructing
rig like she sat there and took all of
his [ __ ] this equally artful takedown of
why therapy is crap but then immediately
she comes back with the idea that he's
the most powerful mind in the universe
but he's completely trapped by all these
human emotions that he doesn't want to
deal with and it's all of his own
choosing all he has to do is choose you
chose to come here you made a choice to
do this in real life Dan Harmon always
makes a lot of jokes about his time with
his therapist as well as the people
around him and now he drives people to
therapy in what they say about him so
he's sort of making fun of himself with
this meta commentary about Ric in the
episode so 5050 you could take either
one of their perspectives they're both
meant to be correct therapies crap or
therapy does help people but if you do
have a problem with eating poop please
call dr. Wong I love the way they kept
working that in there even Morty picks
the book up oh my god people are eating
poop in this so a lot of you did
remember after goldenfold's little funny
moment how long have you been eating
poop that during the interdimensional
cable episode there was a universe where
everybody ate poop so it's a bit of a
subtle wink at that but they also did an
improv episode that I included in one of
my promo videos where they're talking
about poop so maybe they just think a
lot about poop in the writers room
freaked out a little bit when I heard
the Shoney's reference under there a lot
of theory crafters to talk about Rick
being in a coma maybe this is all
happening in his brain the theory that
this is all still happening in the
Shoney's that we've never left there
since the first episode is sort of a
spin-off of that it's all happening in
Rick's mind because the Shoney's is a
place that Rick created within his mind
so loved how they circled back around to
that I wonder how many more times we're
going to hear about Shoney's this season
at the beginning of the episode there's
still a picture of snuffles above their
toilet but you remember that the
snuffles that took over their family and
turned into lawnmower dog was from the
Cronenberg world which Rick also
mentions during the episode when he's
talking to Jaguar about his daughter he
says he abandoned one of his daughters
on earth that was taken over by mutant
so that's Cronenberg world so that's the
second time we've heard about it this
season and I love the way he dodges
Jaguars question right after that wait a
minute do I have infinite daughters too
because the one on this earth has
already been killed nope nope just me
I'm the only one that has multiple
daughters but the other big guest
are during the episode you may not have
recognized right away is Peter
Serafinowicz he's the guy that's playing
the new version of the tick he played
the Hans Gruber character it felt a
little die hard II like it was all meant
to be this 90 action movie parody but
when he started talking about the
hundred million dollar in bonds I was
like oh wait a minute wasn't that the
plot of die hard when they were trying
to steal the bonds out of the safe but
the Jaguar stuff they're keeping him
locked up and forcing him to work for
them because they have his daughter
that's the plot of commando big
Schwarzenegger movie it kind of makes
you want to watch some of these movies
after you spot these Easter eggs
when Jaguars chasing him down the hall
he does the Van Damme splits which i
think is actually written into Van Dam's
contracts and all the 80s and 90s movies
that he did he has to do the splits at
least once per movie if you heard a very
familiar scream during the episode that
was the henchmen doing the starcraft
terran academy scream very identifiable
but also sometimes confused with the
Wilhelm scream the other big Hollywood
funny scream that people work in the
movies and TV shows the rat suit
construction scene was just a big send
up of the Iron Man movie just this giant
bioengineered device designed to graft
rat parts onto his body oh [ __ ] that
pickle has a rat suit in at the
beginning of the episode when he almost
fries in the Sun on the driveway and
says this is the equivalent to a normal
person dying on the toilet he's actually
talking about Elvis Elvis died while he
was on the crapper if you do anything in
this life make sure that you do not die
while you're on the [ __ ] let me know
in the comments though if you spotted
any other Easter eggs or references that
I didn't include in the video overall it
was probably my favorite episode of the
season but there's seven more so I'm
expecting something else to top it there
aren't any more breaks in the season as
far as I know we know the first eight
episodes now so next week will be
Episode four I'll do a promo video for
that in the next day or two but next
week's episode is Vindicator 3 the
return of world ender it's a bit of a
Marvel movie parody there's a line of
dialogue where Morty comes running in we
need to help him out and Rick's like I
don't answer literal calls to action so
fun fact from behind the scenes Dan
Harmon actually did a little punch up on
the Doctor Strange movie like he
actually worked for Marvel for a little
bit to help him out with a
couple scenes so the week after that is
were leaderly conspiracy then rest and
rick slacks ation which we actually got
the scene for i'll add a link to that
video at the end of this because they've
already released the cold open then
after that is tales from the citadel and
then the ABCs of beth so if you couldn't
tell they're spending a lot of time this
season dealing with a lot of backstory
best and rick's relationship which at
times is way more funny than his
relationship with Morty i think they
focus so heavily on Morty the first two
seasons now they're trying to broaden
that out a little bit it how hilarious
is that this summer just cares about
getting high I just want to be known as
a person who just likes to get high
huffing the glaze from pottery enamel in
morty peeing his desk they make a couple
jokes about it but they kind of brush
over it because they focused mostly on
BET's walter in that therapy session but
that's actually pretty serious so
they're being pretty dark and i believe
that this is the first episode that
we're seeing rick spend most of the time
not in human form
not including council of ricks episodes
because you have the infinite versions
of rick so of course there's going to be
a couple versions of rick that don't
look human congratulations to the latest
merch giveaway winner archangel Lopez
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here for the trailer
for next week's game of Thrones and you
can click here for my Rick and Morty
episode 2 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
Oh